[Applause]
Americans who couldn't get interested in
the World Cup no matter how hard they
tried have to stop feeling guilty about
it it doesn't mean that we're not
sophisticated all it proves is that
unemployed people will watch anything on
the bright side it has reminded the
German people how good it feels to be
whipped into a nationalistic frenzy and
what could go wrong with that new role
the woman in England who spent $30,000
on plastic surgery to look like Kim
Kardashian needs to spend a little more
at this point the only black celebrities
you could make a sex tape with is Stevie
Wonder
[Applause]
they don't get the show in England it's
okay new rule now that Marvel Comics has
announced their superhero Thor is now a
woman they have to promise not to make
spider-man gay because I can't think of
a more offensive name for a gay man than
Peter Parker
oh my new rule with all the things going
on in the world John Kerry must
understand this is not the time to play
I believe I can flunk Plus John look
around there Asians all there think all
they're thinking is clearly he did not
master his string instrument by age
three new role the Pope is a pin
I'm serious I find myself wanting to ask
this Pope a question I've never wanted
to ask a pope before can i party with
you
Nero I'm not saying the Japanese can't
make an iPhone case molded on an actual
human vagina yes they did
I'm just saying they have to tell us why
it's awkward enough but dialing now and
who can who can keep up I'm still using
my dictaphone
[Applause]